i
[Música]
hoy se cumplen dos años desde que andrés
manuel lópez obrador llegó al poder en
mexico el mandatario entregó mensaje a
la nación donde reconoció el aumento de
varios delitos a pesar de esto y del
manejo de la pandemia su imagen todavía
es positiva tenemos reportes desde
ciudad de mexico
hace un año el coi 19 apareció por
primera vez en un jardín a más de 63
millones de personas se han contagiado
hasta el momento en todo el mundo pero
más de 40 millones 800 mil se han
recuperado de la enfermedad muchas de
ellas aseguran que aún sufren las buenas
y hoy que se conmemora el día mundial de
la lucha contra el sida la onu alerta
que la pandemia de kobe 19 ha dejado
miles de pacientes sin el tratamiento
más de 1000 de ellos han muerto en el
marco de la emergencia actual vih/sida
afecta a más de 48 millones de personas
en todo el mundo muchas de ellas en
américa latina tenemos análisis en esta
emisión
regresamos con más información de
américa latina y del mundo aquí en las
24 bienvenidos de nuevo yo soy liliana
valencia iniciamos en méxico porque el
presidente andrés manuel lópez obrador
está cumpliendo dos años al mando del
país desde el palacio nacional a los dos
se dirigió a los ciudadanos en un
discurso de balance de gestiones donde
reconoció el aumento de delitos como el
homicidio el feminicidio y la extorsión
pero poco habló sobre el coi 19 veamos
este informe de álvaro cordero crísticas
que él ha pedido con promesas de cambio
andrés manuel lópez obrador llegó al
poder hace dos años pero varias crisis y
palabras por cumplir se han acumulado
durante su mandato la más severa ha sido
la del coronavirus que ha dejado más de
105 mil fallecidos en méxico algo que no
ha evitado que obrador sea uno de los
dirigentes más escépticos respecto a la
pandemia hasta tal punto que no cree en
la eficacia de los confinamientos ni
lleva tapabocas
para combatir la pandemia informó que a
pesar de heredar un sistema de salud en
ruinas minado por la corrupción logramos
terminar de construir 130 hospitales y
reconvertimos 971 para atender pacientes
con cobit 19 con su presidencia se
activó la guardia nacional y como sus
antecesores elevó el gasto militar algo
que no ha servido para cumplir con una
de sus promesas centrales terminar con
la violencia su buena sintonía con
donald trump a pesar de su línea
ideológica y amo la relación e hizo que
la crisis migratoria se enfrentase con
el cierre de fronteras y que se llegase
a un acuerdo de libre comercio con
canadá y eeuu
él teme que pasos que no han solucionado
ni el drama migratorio ni la situación
económica algo que ha hecho que la
oposición se organiza en la calle para
protestar en su contra la verdad mucha
gente creo que votó por él por un cambio
pero esto es demasiado o sea nos está
llevando
a la quiebra a todo el país ya somos
demasiados demasiada gente que ha
perdido su empleo y nada más no se ve
forma de que esta cosa vaya a interesar
a pesar de esto el presidente mexicano
mantiene una popularidad de más del 60%
entre sus ciudadanos quienes siguen
viendo en él una alternativa sólida a
décadas de dominio del pri y el pan
y cambiamos esta información con nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico
-mario carbonell 'mario buenas noches y
cuéntenos el presidente no se refirió
durante mucho tiempo a uno de los
mayores desafíos de su gestión que es
por supuesto el coi 19 que dijo en esta
oportunidad al respecto
así es no abundó mucho en el tema
refirió que en efecto su administración
recibió un sistema hospitalario en el
abandono por lo que tuvieron que
terminar de construir 130 hospitales y
rehabilitar otros 900 70 que fueron
reconvertidos para atender a pacientes
como beat dijo que se dispuso de 32 mil
camas de hospitalización general y más
de 10 mil de hospitalización con
ventilador pero no hizo ninguna alusión
a que pues las cifras que estimaban como
el peor escenario fueron superadas hace
ya varios meses tenemos ahora más de 105
mil muertos por los que si en efecto
dijo que era muy doloroso el
fallecimiento de estos mexicanos a causa
de esta pandemia tampoco se refirió al
mensaje del director de la o ms en el
sentido de que la situación en méxico
era preocupante y que debería tomarse
muy en serio no hablo tampoco de las
críticas o cuestionamientos por la falta
de pruebas suficientes para la detección
temprana del cob y 19 ni tampoco
pues las observaciones que se le han
hecho por la falta del uso de cubrebocas
por ejemplo pero si hablo mario sobre
las cifras de violencia e incluso se
refirió al alto índice de feminicidio en
el país tema del cual casi nunca habla y
eso le ha generado críticas que destaca
usted entonces del discurso de esta
noche del presidente andrés manuel lópez
obrador
efectivamente el presidente reconoció
que si bien hay 8 de los 11 delitos de
alto impacto que tienen una tendencia a
la baja como el robo a casa-habitación
el robo a transeúnte hay tres delitos de
los más digamos de los más sensibles que
no han podido ser controlados es el
homicidio doloso que tiene un alza de
3.8 por ciento el feminicidio de 8.9 por
ciento y la extorsión con un 21% el caso
del feminicidio como bien lo comentas
pues ha sido un tema muy sensible que ha
generado protestas manifestaciones en
las calles de grupos feministas que
exigen que cese esta violencia de género
y que se cree una fiscalía especializada
en temas de feminicidio dijo que pues
esta situación
puedes escuchar de la etapa neoliberal
si es mario kart poner nuestro
corresponsal en ciudad de méxico y
continuamos con más información porque
se cumple un año desde los primeros
casos de ccoo y 19 que se registraron en
la ciudad de wuhan en china éstos
derivaron en la pandemia y la comunidad
científica continúa tratando de entender
más sobre este virus él con 19 miles de
sobrevivientes presentan síntomas a
pesar de haber superado la enfermedad
estos pacientes dicen sentirse solos
ante la falta de información la
respuesta la encontramos con los
diferentes grupos o ellos han encontrado
esta respuesta en diferentes grupos de
apoyo marinas ardilla nos cuenta más en
este informe
en medio de la incertidumbre
generalizada por la pandemia de kobe 19
los primeros pacientes contagiados por
el virus no encontraban respuestas
médicas a su enfermedad el aislamiento y
la falta de información hizo que miles
de personas se sintieran solas ante el
virus ante el escepticismo esta joven
sobreviviente fundó un grupo de apoyo en
línea para pacientes de kobe 19
una de las principales preguntas que los
pacientes tenían para mí aparte de ella
sabes me siento ansioso qué puedo hacer
para sentirme mejor era cómo supiste
cuándo ir al hospital y que hicieron por
ti allá y este tipo de información
táctica realmente útil sigue siendo
intercambiado regularmente desde nueva
york hasta indonesia muchos
sobrevivientes del patógeno continúan
teniendo síntomas persistentes
relacionados con la enfermedad como
dolor de pecho pérdida del cabello o
palpitaciones cardíacas incluso después
de dar negativo como you know que ante
la falta de apoyo por parte del personal
sanitario encontró respuestas dialogando
con otros en internet nosotros a la
fruta
me sentí muy frustrado cuando recibir
respuestas insatisfactorias parecía
pensar que me inventaba historias decía
que me preocupaba demasiado a la
pandemia de kobe 19
conectados a través de las redes algunos
sobrevivientes con secuelas crearon una
campaña para que se reconozca este tipo
de pacientes y no los traten como
hipocondríacos y seguimos haciendo
campaña para que más gente entienda los
problemas de las personas que sufren del
hongo cobit ya sean profesionales de la
salud empleadores y sus familiares y
amigos porque lamentablemente muchos de
los que sufren todavía se enfrentan a la
incredulidad incluso de sus familiares
cercanos
fernández la ms ha reconocido que se
necesita más investigación sobre por qué
perduran los síntomas de coronavirus y
pide a los gobiernos que reconozcan la
afección mientras que los afectados
luchan por ser creídos
cada 1º de diciembre se conmemora a
nivel mundial el día de la lucha contra
el sida este año la fecha está
especialmente dedicada a las
afectaciones que la pandemia de kobe 19
ha generado a miles de pacientes de vih
que no han podido recibir sus
tratamientos más de 48 millones de
personas viven en el mundo con esta
enfermedad que fue descubierta a
principios de los años 80 sólo durante
2019 este virus causó más de 690.000
muertes según onusida a la pandemia de
kobe 19 ha dificultado la batalla contra
el virus pues sólo en este año al menos
1000 pacientes con vih perdieron la vida
en el marco de la emergencia y además
advierten que la situación podría causar
hasta 148 mil muertes adicionales entre
2020 y 2022 analizamos esta información
y nos comunicamos con el doctor césar
antonio núñez director regional de
onusida para américa latina' bienvenida
france24 cuéntenos cuáles son las
consecuencias de la pandemia de ccoo 19
sobre la lucha contra el virus del sida
buenas noches las consecuencias son la
interrupción de la entrega de los
servicios de salud particularmente en lo
que tiene que ver con la entrega
oportuna de los medicamentos
los cuales deben ser recibidos a nuestra
manera de ver por lo menos en grupos de
tres meses para que las personas no
tengan que venir a los centros de
atención adicionalmente el tema de la
protección social para aquellos que más
lo necesitan en américa latina las
desigualdades significan que los menos
los que menos pueden defender sus
derechos siguen siendo los más afectados
las desigualdades en salud nos afectan a
todos y nadie está salvo si están los no
todos estamos a salvo
bueno cual tenemos también que hoy hoy
que tanto se habla de la vacuna contra
el coe 19 cabe reflexionar sobre el
hecho de que hasta ahora no se ha
encontrado una vacuna contra el vih sida
que posibilidad de tratamiento existen
en la actualidad para las personas que
portan este virus
en este momento en la mayoría de los
países del mundo y por supuesto en
américa latina' se cuenta con
medicamentos anterior pro virales
efectivos los cuales lo que han generado
es que el sida se ha convertido en una
enfermedad crónica la persona no muere
más allá de vih o decidida perdón y
puede tener una vida normal la vacuna ha
sido elusiva en cuanto al sida porque la
cubierta del virus muta demasiado
esperamos que con las investigaciones
que generan con el nuevo coronavirus nos
permitan llegar a una innovación que nos
lleven a una vacuna por lo pronto el
estigma la discriminación son elementos
contra los cuales tenemos que luchar y
tenemos que reforzar muchísimo la
prevención para que no siga aumentando
el número de nuevas infecciones y por
último y rápidamente cuéntanos cuáles
son los focos rojos a nivel mundial de
esta enfermedad
a nivel de américa latina' nos
encontramos con países que reportan la
mayor cantidad brasil y méxico- por
número de habitantes en áfrica sigue
siendo áfrica del sur y el continente
prácticamente asiáticos china e india
siguen siendo grandes contribuyentes
importantemente el medicamento está
disponible para la mayoría de las
personas que lo necesitan en estos
lugares pues agradecemos al doctor césar
antonio núñez director regional de
onusida para américa latina y cambiamos
de información porque en alemania al
menos cinco personas murieron entre
ellas un bebé de nueve meses y otras
quince resultaron heridas cuando un
vehículo las invistió en una zona
peatonal en la ciudad de tréveris en el
estado de renania palatinado el
conductor un ciudadano alemán de 150
años fue capturado e interrogado por la
policía alemana que ya investiga los
móviles del hecho
en un hecho que trae a la memoria los
ataques terroristas este martes un coche
atravesó una calle peatonal en la ciudad
de tréveris en el suroeste de alemania
cobrando varias vidas entre los muertos
está un bebé de nueve meses además 15
personas resultaron heridas
veíamos estas imágenes en la televisión
de otros países y pensábamos esto no
puede pasar entre betis y ahora sucedió
en tréveris y estoy aquí como alcalde y
me quedo sin palabras
el conductor identificado como un
ciudadano alemán de 51 años fue
arrestado en la escena no tenía
domicilio fijo y estaba viviendo en el
landrover que fue usado en el ataque
nuestros pensamientos están con los
familiares de las víctimas que ahora
tienen que llorar la muerte de un ser
querido
de personas cuyas vidas se extendieron
de un segundo a otro por un crimen tan
atroz
el fiscal encargado de la investigación
dijo que el conductor estaba bajo la
influencia del alcohol y agregó que
podría estar sufriendo una enfermedad
mental
el interrogatorio está en curso así que
no podemos decir nada aún sobre su
motivo amaba
comer no tenemos indicios de que el
motivo sea de naturaleza terrorista
política o religiosa
el incidente trajo a la memoria del
ataque de un camión en un mercado
navideño de berlín que dejó 12 personas
muertas en 2016 el ataque yihadista más
mortífero de alemania hasta la fecha
el presidente electo de estados unidos
joe biden presentó oficialmente a los
integrantes de su equipo económico la
nominada como secretaria del tesoro
janet yellen alertó sobre la que
calificó de tragedia económica que se
vive en el país a causa de la pandemia
de kobe 19 y que ya deja más de 269.000
fallecidos y miles de personas sin
empleo
helen e sostuvo que es necesario actuar
con urgencia ante la crítica situación
las vidas perdidas empleos perdidos
pequeñas empresas que luchan por
mantenerse vivas o cerradas para siempre
tantas personas que luchan para poner
comida en la mesa pagar las cuentas y el
alquiler es una tragedia estadounidenses
en denver quien preside así finalizamos
por esta emisión en france 24 pero los
invitamos a continuar con más en nuestra
página web www punto frente y 4 punto
como información de américa latina en
cuatro idiomas y también del mundo
entero nos vemos más adelante con más
información
[Música]
el espacio de france vent